effectivement le tramway urbain qui
roule sur une rue ordinaire le
tram-train qui peut s'appuyer à la fois
sur une rue aussi sur une voie réservée
aux trams trains
le clr de la mt est dans une toute autre
catégorie
c'est un métro de surface automatiser la
photo officielle utilisée depuis le
milieu des années 2000 dans plusieurs
des publications de limiter provident
son consultant équipe slr métropolitain
toujours le même train en bleu en verre
en gris métallique remarqué ce sont les
mêmes voitures en arrière-plan
c'est une photo basé sur un train
bombardier le mark ii qui roule sur le
réseau skytrain de vancouver ont la
transplanter au milieu de l'autoroute 10
grâce à la magie d'un logiciel